How does this whole thing and, uh,
probably in tears for who who's crying is everybody crying.
Who's crying. When,
so I think there were some of the hedge funds that were crying initially that
maybe some of the wall street bets, people who bought last would be crying.
And then eventually there's probably another set of hedge funds or even the wall
street bets mob, and the, you know, that army,
some of them might've broke ranks and then shorted the stock. So nobody knows.
So everybody has to be aware of what's happening in the game.
So if wall street bet said, Hey,
let's squeeze these hedge funds because they have too much short interest.
Let's all buy the stock. Then some of them might've said, okay, you know,
it's at three, two or $300. Maybe I'll join the short movement.
Now that they've covered.
And they could have shorted there in been like double agents.
So people have to understand, like, this stuff is gnarly and it's a,
it's a free for all. I mean, it is a literal free.
There's a kind of morality,
like a big statement that lost your bets made in terms of like the elites
can't just push us around. They can't bully around. But at the same time,
you know, they're also interested in making money, right? Because it is, uh,
what's your sons.
You said that some of the people in the wash your best might've broken off and
shorted the stock, are they more interested? There was an emergent,
like morality that emerged and said, like,
we're not going to put up with the centralized leads,
but is that going to continue or are they going to fight the power
structures that are bad for society? Or are they going to now, like,
I mean, are they ultimately going to introduce more chaos?
That's going to damage the economy and damage the world,
or are they going to continue being the good guys and fighting the, uh, the,
the, the evils that manipulate, uh, the market was your sense?
You know, it, it really feels like the dark nights series of films where like,
some people just want to see the world burn.
I think there is a contingent of people who just literally want to see chaos.
Like, you know, that contingent on some of these, you know,
forums who just want to create chaos. Right? Yeah. Um,
so there there's certainly that chaos contingent,
but I think overall what the arc will show is a group of people getting
massively educated. You see it in crypto as well.
There was like a three-year period where all of these failed
entrepreneurs who I knew who couldn't build companies were then coming
back to me after their companies has failed or after they gave up,
or couldn't clear market raising money with the venture capital community.
And they were doing ICO's and I was like, I met you before. Right.
And they're like, yeah, yeah, yeah, no, I'm doing an ICO now. I'm like, okay,
where's your company at? And they're like, here's a white paper.
And I was like this white paper with spelling errors in it that says you're
going to destroy Airbnb because everybody's apartment is going to be on an
immutable ledger. Like,
wouldn't that be better in a regular database that was private and not public?
Like, why does it need to be on an immutable ledger? So it can't change.
I'm like not changing the database is a feature that's that does not seem a good
feature. And they couldn't explain it. They're like, well,
just people are interested in ICO's and there was that ICO mania.
And what it showed was there's a global appetite for risk.
People want to try new things.
This is one of the great things about the human spirit is one of the great
things about capitalism.